*casual bongos music plays*
where is it?
Where is it?
(what have you lost now?)
...
Well, it's not there.
where is it?
Ga-
Garble?
thank you..
*pleasure noises*
that feels good, thank you Garble
my best friend
you've been there since the beginning
since 0 subs
Garble was here
Birdabo...
*brain fuck*
level 2 0
( Brad was salt)
we have to wear this shirt in every shot
if you see us not wearing the shirt, we get a strike
the one with the most strikes after 21 days...
Brad: after 21 days has to go to a cheap tattoo parlor and get an American flag tattoo
*all laugh like fucking retards*
so that's what's happening with the shirt, in case you don't know
I have to go to the gym today
which i have a bunch of problems with 'cause A-
you can see i'm in my underwear dammit
number one it's the nearest
gym is like 30 minutes away
number two I have to wear this shirt to
the gym and I can't take it off
number 3 i'm jet lagged and i have a
headache and i I'm really excited
about this vlog today let me tell you
more about what's going to happen today
(poods?)
today starts the first day of scare pewdiepie
and my call time is at 10pm
last night I went to sleep at that time
and I was very very tired and I was
supposed to be done at 4am
i'm going to die
today today's video just went out let's
check some comments
*scrolls through comments to find...*
"your content is shit again"
*fancy music plays*
alright so now i'm going to rent a car
for LA
I don't know why I specified that
*Hip music plays*
*hip music continues to play*
*hip music plays for alittle too long*
(will it ever stop?)
(the answer is no)
*hip music comes to an end*
I think we're going for this one but i'm
pretty sure Marzia would want that one
'cause it's the ugliest one
it's really ugly
all right now I recognized for the first time
hi from Finland?
cool guy: yeah
how do you say that?
Cool guy: hello from Finland
okay well thats English
okay so
(sweet ride)
this is my car
I picked it because Marzia loves
squared ugly cars
it's my lambo
got pretty nice got pretty sweet rims
Nexen that's a really good
really good brand
I'm on the wrong side
fuck how do I Drive
(don't you have a licence?)
oh my god
it's like
driving in LA is bad enough
driving with a new car on the wrong side
of the road with no GPS
I don't even know how the fuck to get
back i didn't think this through
i should have just gotten like a nice tesla
or some fucking shit but it's OH MY GOD
IT'S AUTOMATIC
where's the gas peddle
awww
#savePoods
i'm legit scared
right now
i don't know what the fuck today
Oh God alright I'm gonna stop vlogging now
Oh God
*fancy music again*
I'm home
Marzia: hi
thank you for cooking
marzia: you're welcome
what did you make man
hey! it's Italian Meatballs
Swedish Italian Meatballs
*strange voice* thank you Marzia
am i supposed to eat with my hands?
(yes.)
get me my cutlery
(DONT BULLY MARZIA)
can you believe
okay let's give this a go
*he pentatrates his food with his utensil*
*he then lets food enter his mouth*
"oh my god" he says
"do you like it?" Marzia ask
"it's really good" he replies
i dont know what it is with like
food the day after, its better
Marzia: it's because i made it with love
<3
thank you
*intense music plays*
something was in here
I swear I saw something in here
Marzia: how big was it? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I don't know
it's something made a move here
*gets scared*
(get it.....)
(Scare! pewdiepie)
there's something
it's something scary!
where is it?
oh my god
unamused Marzia: oh wow
it was garble!
garble what were you doing there?
oh my god you scared- he scared me
that was crazy
okay i'm gonna show Marzia the car
i hope you like it Marzia
are you excited Marzia?
Marzia: very excited
very excited
can't really film here
Marzia: YES IT IS THE ONE
it's the one you wanted
the squared one i  knew you'd like to square one
wait so I got Ga-
GARBLE
what are you
he's always up to something
oh my god where are you going
Garbles come here
lets get you out
it's stupid
*fancy music that is fancy*
okay we're goint to get some halloween costumes
i start working at five today so we won't be
much of a halloween thanks for that youtube
garbles look after the house while i'm gone
Brad: so where are we going Marzia
Marzia: we're going to goodwill, which is a thrift store
to get costumes for Halloween
(seatbelts can be deadly)
I might pick up something for me
actually while I'm here we need to get
Brad: Michael, lets buy Michael a birthday presant
Brad: I feel like we should get
something really weird or really bad
it's very moving
for the vlog
(NOW THATS FASHION)
DIsgusting
i like it
(poods no please stop)
can't handle it
we can buy a printer
and then we can print the picture of us
yeah?
hold on buddy you just came...
out of the closet!
hey! edit that out i'm serious
no edit that out, edit that out
(what?)
my pumpkin pumpkin ball
*fast fancy music*
(......)
gotta change into my outfit
*bubbley music*
i'm wearing the shirt don't you worry about it
Michael what are you doing
(Michael want a scooby snack?)
*bubble music continuies*
so I'm a little bummed out because we
don't get to really celebrate halloween
because i have to work the first scare
shoot starts at five but we're going to
hang out a little bit before we're going
to carve some pumpkins or whatever so we
get to do a little bit what can you do i
was really excited to celebrate
halloween in America 'cause they do it so
well, well look who's coming
look who's here
is he waering his shirt?
yeah, he's wearing his shirt
hey!
no Brad you fail
Brad: wait a second
I'm wearing it
Brad: you're not wearing it
i'm wearing it
Brad: its not on!
yeah it doesn't matter and it's on my body
Brad: it should be at least underneath
yeah viewers am I wearing it right now
as a scarf
I'm I wearing this scarf
Michael: I don't think so yeah
I think so
Brad turn around
Brad: why does it look this way?
its a Trump wig!
*Brad in fake voice* it's time to make scooby-doo great again
* bubble music while they pose*
ok I'm not allowed to fuck with anyone
shirt but they just left their shirts
Marzia: why are you bringing me here
so you have to do this, you have to
please Marzia it's my only chance, come on
Marzia: why do i have to be the one
you go
i can't, i can't do it that was the
rules that I can't do it directly
they're out there, this is the point of the game
Marzia is too innocent for this
i'm literally forcing her to do this
Marzia: i hate you so much
nipple number one
is that even where the nipples are?
poods: yeah okay let's not tell them anything
I'm so happy thank you so much Marzia
*evil laugh*
don't tell him okay
*pumkin cutting bubble music*
oh meh gurd guys
oh my god that's adorable
look at that
thats me and Marzias
Brad: and Brads!
DAMMIT BRAD, everytime
Brads pumpkin: hey guys,I want to be part of the picture
poods pumpkin: no dammit, get the fuck away Brad
Brads pumpkin: oh please i want to be in it too
well ain't that beautiful
look at that
leave a comment which one is the best
Brad: thats really scare pewdiepie
Europeans are fascinated by the
what is it called?
waste disposal
(garbage disposal)
we don't have it in Europe ok guys we don't
know what is like right i got 10 minutes
until i'm getting picked up by scared by
Scare Pewdiepie it begins now
Michael: film him, film, film him,
GOT YOU BITCH
Brad: WHY
WHY ARE YOU CONSPIERING?
poods: HELL YEAH
now put it on and look at thoses nippels
Brad: who did this
Marzia did
oh she cut it perfectly
she cut it perfectly!
(he has nice nips why is he like this)
Brad: are you serious
Marzia: HE PROMISED ME A PUG
Brad: i am always your friend, i am always on your side
that is the end of our relationship as friends
poods: the nipples are so good
Velma: oh my god
i saw this happening everyone even Marzia turned on me
*bubble music while we watch te children play*
it's time, it begins now. wait we all got
the fucking shirt
hell yeah
( i want to feel Brads nippys)
the cars here
this has literally
been the whole season one just sitting
in the back of a van
but now you guys are here!
and michael as scooby-do
*chill hip music plays*
(he thinks)
*chill hip music continues*
we've stopped after how long ever
been driving two hours
Jesus Christ I'm ready to go to sleep
oh you put it up
so now they're blocking out the windows
right all right here it goes
I think I know what game it is
i think its Outlast
fucking hell
that's sexual harassment
Brad: what are you expecting to see when you get out
ahh something really horrifying
like your mom's dick
Brad: TOUCH HIS BUTT
TOUCH HIS BUTT
lady: i touch a lot of dudes butts
that aren't my boyfriends
*chill hip to watch the magic happen*
i'll go this way
this seems, has anyone
tested this does not seem safe
Brad: this is twenty bucks to fuck
with Felix shirt
Michael: what do you want to draw on it
Brad: put like a little dick hanging down just
from the flag like just like a flag
stick and on the back for i heart Michael
he hates michael
wanna wear your little shirt
want to keep wearing it?
*hips music as Tyler draws*
Michael: pewdiepie how was it
poods: that was horrible, i want to go home. i'm so sick i'm
really cold what the hell is happening
I got my shower here to
its a portable a little shower
it's 2am we started at five thirty such
a long day it was awesome though I'm just
ready to go home
Michael: how is it
*pewds pleasure noises*
it feels so fucking good
oh my god
thanks for watching part 2 of  birdabo
this was a crazy day it really
they stepped it up from the last season
this is like 10 times more
it's crazy i can't believe it, i hope
you guys are enjoying the vlog's
i'll see you tomorrow with another birdabo
brofist
( UH OH POODS)
so we're back to another end
remember to sub to this channel
WE'RE AT 49 MIL?
MAKE SURE ALL YOUR FAM FAM SUBS
btw thanks to all the people who stayed til the end yesterday
and commented about brad...
its great...
still here?
want another # for the comments?
too bad i'm not very creative...
#saltybrad